i want to know where your character fits
into the saga tell me anything you're
allowed to tease me sure i'm uh king of
the elves yes you are
each of us
must decide who we shall be
he was one of the elves that chose to
stay and protect middle earth and that's
his job and as we know in tolkien evil
is always right around the corner so he
certainly has his hands full
i play a human from the southlands i'm a
healer i'm a mother of a somewhat
rebellious teenage son but i'm also in
this forbidden romance with an elf so
it's sort of like the love story of the
season we find him in the southlands
so he is watching over the people
they've colonized that area and that
that's where the tricky part happens in
terms of his love for a human
you just hear
the moment we feared
cate blanchett previously portraying do
you talk to the actress do you reach out
i don't talk to kate bloodshed but i
think about her all the time
honestly like those films and her and
ardwen i was just so obsessed with so it
still
feels very surreal well my character is
kelebrimbor who uh ultimately forges the
rings of power
but we're not there yet he's trying to
build a kind of heaven on earth for the
for the elves to because they're in a
sad place the elf at this point and uh
keller moore is is uh trying to
build a city where they can all um try
and reclaim some of that lost
valinorness about them your characters
from both the books and the films um
with hugo weaving previously portraying
it's a sort of right-hand man to the
king he's not a lord yet um he's very
interested in different peoples of
middle earth which we we get to see a
little bit of destroy it
there's definitely a weight of
expectation on my shoulders to
to kind of fulfill everyone's idea
because they have a sense of ownership
over this character he wants to on one
hand fulfill his father's dream
but also there's like this deep yearning
for something else a soldier's sister
she's the baby of the family
she's an aspiring architect on the cusp
of womanhood
a little insecure
smarter than she realizes you play a
character created for the series so does
that take pressure off or is that
additional pressure i think it's a
different kind of pressure i think
there's some really interesting things
in the character he's built on the
foundations of tolkien's work we meet
him floating on a raft in the middle of
the sundering seas he's leaving behind
something in his past and he's moving
forward towards something else my
character's name is largo he's the
father of nori
he's a hard-foot prehistoric hobbit
um
what an amazing thing to say i can't
even believe i'm saying it my character
nori brownie foot she's a really
resolute inquisitive curious half foot
she's a troublemaker
um but she just wants to improve the
half foot's quality of life and does so
by by
taking risks she is there with nori and
her love for nori and poppy is the kind
of one who likes to draw her back in i
feel like the sons of powerful people
and i think his dad's frustration is
that um he's not bringing many new ideas
to the table because the current ideas
are suiting him pretty well i'm playing
a human that's like you know a new
character so i get to you know sort of
make up my own storyline for my
character so i play the character of
princess diesel she is the first
female dwarf that we will ever see on
screen
she is the first um
dwarf of color to be able to host this
moment and make this huge franchise
accessible for all the generations
across the screen is an iconic moment
for me and and hopefully for the world
to draw in the new fans and know that it
is possible during he's the prince so
he's kind of in line to the throne in in
kaza doom
and we make them a very um
fruitful life i suppose you saw it at
the end of the trailer there might be a
big thing there somewhere
there can be no trust between hammer and
rock
eventually one or the other
must surely big
[Music]